happy Halloween although technically in
Australia where we're shooting this it's
November 1st and the scariest thing
going on is all this junk yeah we're
moving office 28 first reveal
battlefield 1 there was some concern
that they've been making light of the
horrors of war what ultimately came out
was a pretty excellent game that was
fairly sensitive to the subject matter
then they released some tweets over the
weekend the battlefield Twitter account
began using the hashtag just world war 1
things
yeah the cringe is just getting started
one such tweet showed a gif of the
soldier being burnt to death by a
flamethrower with the caption when
you're too hot for the club yeh have
since apologized for the tweets telling
GameSpot we would like to apologize for
any offence caused by content in the
last 24 hours posted on the battlefield
Twitter account it did not treat the
World War one error with the respect and
sensitivity that we have strived to
maintain with the game and our
communications let's not forget that not
too long ago EA executive Peter Moore
tweeted out a picture of himself wearing
a battlefield onesie with the caption
trench warfare requires schulte
equipment and clothing
this is born the battlefield onesie with
pockets for melee weapons and Doritos
way too awkward next story deadly
permission direct astray 65 announced he
is leaving access games the veteran dev
said he would be taking a short break
from game development over a year ago
and has now tweeted day 360
unfortunately I retired from access
games after all however don't worry
because my health condition is getting
to be fine love you
last year's very rebuilt he was
recovering from reactive hypoglycemia at
the time he added that when he recovers
he'll be making even better games oh
hopefully we see him back in game
development sometime soon
finally insensitive means or no
battlefield one is still top of the
sales charts in the UK
yeah and Isis shooter remains in the top
slot even after the release of titanfall
2 this week sales have not dropped off
as significantly as they did for
battlefield 3 and battlefield 4 in their
second weeks
Skyrim special edition debuted in the
number two spot which makes it the
second best debut week in the Elder
Scrolls series behind the original
Skyrim titanfall tears come in at number
four on the sales charts despite being
available on more platforms from the
original titanfall which debuted at
number one in its first week of sales
you can check out the full top 10 list
in our story on site finally a reminder
the game spot will be taking on extra
life again this year across our three
territories so keep an eye out for that